[Music]
good evening welcome to a special
edition of Tucker Carlson tonight this
Friday the thing about climate change is
it's serious stuff very serious it's not
like the frivolous concerns that fill
your days like paying your bills or
keeping your marriage together putting
your kids through school or fighting
cancer climate change is bigger than
that way bigger it's about saving the
earth it's about taking on what we're
gonna call a existential threat to
humanity it's a big deal man nobody
understands the gravity of climate
change with quite the soul searing
intensity of freshman congresswoman
Alexandria Kazuya Cortez where cosmic
Cortes talks about climate change in the
green new deal she promises will save us
from climate change she often looks like
she's gonna start to cry or start to
yell or both and why wouldn't she it's
scary as hell time is running out the
world is going to end in 12 years if we
don't address climate change like this
is the war this is our world war two now
you can disagree with the details of the
green new deal she's proposing banning
cars and airplanes for example shutting
down the entire American energy sector
rebuilding every dwelling in the United
States you could disagree with that but
what you can't question is Acacio
Cortez's sincerity when she talks about
climate change clearly she really means
it or does she
this is a man called psyche cat
chakrabarti he's Alexander Acacio
cortezes chief of staff over in the
Congress he personally led the writing
of the green New Deal The Washington
Post just profiled Chakrabarti in the
interview Chakrabarti made his stunning
admission all that stuff about the world
ending 12 years to save the planet it
was all alive chakrabarti is not worried
about humanity's demise the green New
Deal has nothing to do with that here's
what he told the paper quote the
interesting thing about the green new
deal is it wasn't originally a climate
thing at all do you guys think it was a
climate thing because we really think of
it as a how do you change the entire
economy thing end quote
that's about as direct as it could be
the greener deal is not designed to save
the world it's not about the environment
at all it's about power Chakrabarti
Anacostia Cortez want control of the
American economy they went looking for
an issue who would justify a hostile
takeover of the economy climate change
seems scary so they went with that
it's remarkable they're admitting this
but we shouldn't be surprised it's
happening this kind of thing happens all
the time
manufacturing crises is the last
preferred way to exert control over the
country
a decade ago for example only wackos and
bedsheets were called racists then
during the last election Donald Trump
was denounced as a racist now Nancy
Pelosi and Joe Biden are being written
off as racists what's going on here it's
not like there's more racism in the
country in fact there's much less than
there used to be what changed is that
the left realized they could gain power
by creating boogeymen by scaring you
stupefy the masses with fear-mongering
by the time they've recovered you're the
one in charge that's their program
Robert Hakan vies to Alexandria Casa de
cortes on the green New Deal is also a
law and finance professor at Cornell
University and he joins us tonight
professor thanks for coming on oh hey
Tucker thanks for having me so you can
imagine how some of us feel betrayed
surprised scammed I mean they're
admitting Acacio Cortez's office
Chakrabarti is admitting that the
greener deal isn't really about climate
change or the environment it's about
control of the economy why shouldn't we
be shocked and offended to learn this
well if two things really as I could
from the very beginning it's actually
combined right environmental cleanup and
abatement on the one hand and
modernization of the economy on the
other hand it's not meant to be a
takeover the economy it's meant to be a
continuation of what historically has
always been a great partnership between
our federal government on the one hand
and the private sector that makes up our
economy on the other hand the most
vibrant sector in the American economy
is the energy sector and the green New
Deal would eliminate it it would it
would literally eliminate it it would
also actually resume to control at will
that's what it says well and I believe
we debated this before it was it would
upgrade it yeah it would
I mean it's not we do a media neutrality
but yeah it would operate it only the
other advanced economies who would end
it yeah but Tucker you know all the
other advanced economies in the world
are gradually transitioning away from
carbon-based energy right all of them
are we're simply going to join with the
rest of them in doing that right we're
kind of lagging behind but but wait a
second way to say now now I'm doubly
confused so you're saying it is about
climate but Chakrabarti who's apparently
the guy who oversaw the writing of it
says it really isn't that's just a
pretext yeah I think you're fixating on
control yeah I think you're fixating on
one sentence I mean I'm definitely
fixating yeah yeah so sure I caught all
along I mean all of us involved in the
green new New Deal project all along
have thought of this as a massive
upgrade of American infrastructure to
bring us into the 21st century that in
turn is going to be a green off'
occasion because there just isn't new
are contend of new infrastructure that
isn't green right so if you're gonna be
state-of-the-art you are by definition
becoming green we don't make old kind of
carbon-based infrastructure anymore
anymore than we make you know whale oil
lamps any long okay but but but what
this is okay so the effect of this is to
allow people like you and Chakrabarti
neither of whom are elected Acacio
Cortes who's just elected 20 minutes ago
and to have an amazing amount of control
over the way the rest of us live how do
you get that control you get that
control by scaring the hell out of us
when there was nonsense but there's a
real desire there's no there's really no
desire for control Tucker it's really
about facilitation it's about bringing
finance and that's available well you
can chuckle all you like but when it's
just really the case it really is the
case because of course it's all about
consumers all about controlling what you
know so this is a gross law telling
people what to do no it's not well it's
a resolution it's a resolution calling
for a set of programs to transition the
economy into a state-of-the-art green
infrastructure economy right this is
what other countries have done already
this is why China is a euphemism I know
there's a lot you see what this is about
at some point no no Tucker this is place
to suggestion
look no it's look at what China's doing
okay China now produces and consumes by
far the greater part of solar energy
right all of those photovoltaic panels
we invented that stuff we used to be the
principal manufacturer of it and the
principal we were and we were the
principal exporter of it and we've just
given that to China we've also given
high speed rail to China we restructured
to try no why don't we take that map
you're writing they write that China has
ripped off our intellectual property
evasion okay go ahead my last point you
say it's not about control it's purely
voluntary notation its association the
idea is and then you put into China to
the fascist government of China as an
example of nowhere 300 what you admire
well you what you don't understand I'm
not admire China but I'm say the Chinese
government actually aged Chinese
industry our government does not aid
American industry now as you know Calvin
Coolidge as right now I'm with you on
that well good that's the thing is I
have been thinking all along that you
and I and the rest of us are actually on
the same team there's just a lot of
misunderstanding as to what we're
actually trying to advocate we actually
I'll tell you why our admission use okay
many of your many of your recent the
clients can change as a way to terrify
no we're not trying to terrify you no
it's very urgent
tucker it is urgent but we're not trying
to terrify anybody we're trying to
convince people that what we really have
to do is restore the old American system
of collaboration between the government
and industry in order to facilitate
better financing of again a
state-of-the-art green' infrastructure
we want to be the principal manufacturer
in the world we want to be the principal
of the most the most modern
infrastructure in the world we want to
be the fastest growing economy in the
world we want all of that we used to be
able to do that in the way we did it was
by having the government collaborate
with business but hard to do that now
part of this is right part of it is
dishonest but no it's not it's not
dishonest [ __ ] is everybody's Marco
Rubio I think yeah making your case
tonight okay thanks doc I have